- This is my favorite
thing I actually learned.
I feel like I was talking to
Sophia when I learned that
you're really into "Dungeons and Dragons."
And you have like a club.
- Yeah, sure.
You know, I played as a
kid and then as an adult
I actually, I like work with the company
which is the job I wanted as a kid.
So I get to write stories
that have been published
you know, in their adventure modules.
I created a bunch of characters that
are sold in packages like action figures.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Joe] And yeah,
this is my game.
That's my brother with the big beard.
There's me, I built this whole ice castle
on the dining room table.
That's Tom Morello,
the guitarist from Rage
Against the Machine.
There's, Vince Vaughn.
- [Kelly] This is crazy.
- [Joe] Dan Weiss
co-creator of "Game of Thrones."
Director Kyle Newman.
That's Ryan Vernier who helped to create
"League of Legends."
That's my buddy George in the front,
who's was a great actor.
- Look how excited you are.
- Yeah, I mean, we're just having a blast.
And, so this is my game that I run
every Friday night that
I'm not working in there
or that I'm in town.
And this is the whole group was a bunch of
like visionaries in,
you know, A list people in
the active entertainment world
who grew up and developed
those skills playing this game.
- You've actually used
"Dungeons and Dragons"
as a way to help kids, right?
Sick kids.
- Yeah, I'm on the board of trustees
at Pittsburgh Children's Hospital
and have been for a long time.
And,
I had this idea, you know,
what, I visit the hospital
I visited the kids and
there were a lot of these kids who
are there battling really
serious illnesses and,
sometimes they're in the
hospital for months at a time
and their parents are working.
So they don't have anybody there
from their immediate
family staying with them,
except for the other kids.
And, sometimes kids are hooked up to an IV
for hours at a time getting
an infusion or something.
And, I thought,
one of the beauty beautiful
things about "D and D" is that
you go into this other
world and you're not you.
And it's a super immersive.
- That's what I like
fantasy stuff like that.
- And I thought maybe that
would work for the kids.
That at least for a few hours
they could not have to be them
and deal with what they were dealing with
and escape and play a character.
And it works.
And so I had "Dungeons and Dragons"
send crates full of boxes and dice.
And I, my brother and
I went to the hospital
and taught the kids how to play.
And I had dungeon master like
an adventure with goblins and
you know, things like that for them.
And, they just, they loved it.
And, I hope it's carried on.
But we tried to plant that seed
that this was a way for
you to kinda get out of
the everyday.
- Absolutely.
And that escapism is so
important for everyone.
And especially if you're stuck
and I think this year everybody
can relate to that more than
anybody, we're all kind of stuck inside
and not doing our normal,
you know, routines.